hey there metaphysical milkshakers it's
me rain wilson and it's me reza aslan
how you doing ring well i've been better
i'll be honest what's going on man
what's going on well tell me talk to me
the world it needs a lot of change in
reza and uh sometimes it gets me down
things uh
things are hard and um it's a lot of
[ __ ] going on we need to think about uh
making the world a better place
i listen i'm i'm way ahead of you what
what are you doing what are you doing to
make the world a better place here well
you know i do what i can uh a recycle
um
sometimes at a starbucks i'll buy a
coffee for the person behind me i'll
pick up their tab
okay before the pandemic i would help
little old ladies across the street and
i hear sometimes that the banks are
running low on pennies so we'll collect
the pennies and we'll roll them and take
them in
to the bank so i feel like i'm doing my
part you know doing my share basically
nothing what are you doing to make the
world a better place i wasn't going to
talk about this but uh you know i my
entire family and i have now moved into
a yurt a what a york a yort it's a
traditional uh tent-like structure
usually you find them in like the yukon
or in the mongolian plains that's where
we are in the in in mongolia now
uh and that's where we live now off
totally off the grid you're not off the
grid you're speaking into a microphone
and you're communicating with me via
wi-fi
well i brought this setup with me and we
have netflix i mean we're not animals
obviously but uh but yeah i mean look
this is you you're all about like these
little changes you know buy the guy a
coffee behind you and and like put your
hands in the recycling this is how we're
going to make the world a better place
you've got to see my friend somewhere
one small step at a time are you telling
me you seriously have moved your family
i bet you're starting a cult out there
in mongolia did other people move out
there with you are they gathered around
to hear your nightly sermons
i have a few wives but it's necessary
because
i truly like i am of the opinion that
there is no like little fixes to what
ails us as a society that's time to burn
the [ __ ] thing down that's a big
statement start all over again
bring all my books with me and of course
my podcasting equipment because i have
to tell people that i'm starting all
over again
and uh and just just start a new like
rebuild civilization from the ground up
that's that's that's how i think about
it you might be on to something because
uh with climate change in the future and
so many other uh
gargantuan issues in front of us maybe
we do need wholesale change and not
incremental change
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
so
i know who to talk to about this
wow what the great the one and only
naomi klein
not naomi wolf different naomi right
different ones one's crazy and one is
smart oh okay we got the smart one okay
so you're talking about the author of no
logo and this changes everything
capitalism versus the climate naomi
klein i'm talking about the author of
the shock doctrine and the take and
fences and windows that naomi climbs
fantastic i love her let's get her in
here naomi klein of course is a
award-winning uh
best-selling author and thinker she
writes about
uh global economics and the free market
and climate uh she happens to be
radiohead's favorite author which i will
forever hate her for
uh she
uh lives in canada she's actually
canadian
did you know that about naomi klein she
could not know that i did not know that
she was i just assume
like everybody's american i don't know
malcolm gladwell's canadian we've we've
had way too many canadians on this show
no for real yeah we gotta lower our
canadian quotient just slightly uh after
naomi um and uh she has a new book she's
got a brand new book this one is for
kids
it's called
how to change everything so uh how to
change everything maybe this has some of
the answers we've been looking for
that's what we're gonna talk about
that's exactly where we're gonna how do
we change everything naomi klein
help us help us out with this
naive klein thank you so much for
joining us on the metaphysical milkshake
pod we are long time fans of yours uh as
i was gushing about you uh off camera
the new book is called how to change
everything i'm so excited to talk about
this this is a big deal for us like you
know we've had some pretty big guests
not like naomi klein big
that's right you know we've like malcolm
gladwell like who cares about that guy
honestly
overrated right am i right the dude is
fast he just ran a race he's like 50 no
he's like 60. he's not 60. he's 58 years
old he ran a mile in five minutes and 15
seconds jesus naomi truly a pleasure to
meet you and um to get to know your work
in in preparation for this interview so
excited to have you here and um really
excited for this topic this is uh this
is a question that reza and i struggle
with we deal with we ponder we go back
and forth on a great deal
and
it really was that honestly the the
title of this episode is the title of
your book how convenient how to change
everything because we would love to
discuss this idea of
changing everything how is change
actually achieved but let's get uh let's
start specifically with your book it's
written for specifically a young
audience
and you write in the book the book is a
celebration of a youth movement that is
internationalist multiracial and
peaceful
but militant
and radical do you worry about you
probably get asked this question a lot
about the appropriateness of of having
this discussion with uh you know 12 year
olds and all of these hard-hitting facts
yeah i think about it a lot and to be
honest with you my my son is um he's
turning nine in a couple of weeks
i
don't um this book isn't for him i i
think that that i've read parts of it
with him but i i edit it um as i read um
which i do anyway i do that with harry
potter i'm like hermione's awesome why
do you keep making her feel bad i'm like
and everyone said good for you hermione
for being so smart everyone needs to
edit harry potter because
she writes in 1700 pages what could be
written in about 400 pages
as you know you know the book starts
with this story of going to the great
barrier reef
um when he was only
he was only
four at the time and he just learned to
swim and
um
and describing his sort of joy and
wonder
at discovering that there is this world
under the sea
um a magical there really is a magical
world under the sea for now
for now and but you know he saw one part
but there were lots of other parts that
were that had died off and that's why i
was there i was there making a short
film for the guardian
um and
you know when as i got to that part in
the book i just kind of
moved a few pages forward because
i i think for very young kids our job as
parents is to the extent that we can
is to connect them to the natural world
give them as many positive experiences
in nature as we possibly can because
they are inheriting a world on fire they
are going to have to fight for it and
it's better if they can fight from a
place of love and connection right like
i i i
we fight better that way when we're
fighting for something that we love
right um and i've you know i tell the
story in the book of of meeting an
amazing young woman named takata ironize
at standing rock who when she was just
11 started a movement with her friends
to stop the dakota access pipeline
they weren't fighting against the
pipeline they were fighting for their
water they were fighting for their land
and so
the more we can
create those positive experiences where
kids know what they're fighting for the
better off they will be when they do
have to join the climate movement
because we're all going to have to be in
it one way or another
but you know this question of like how
do we protect our kids and
you know my son does know about climate
change not because i thought he was
ready to learn about it when he was five
but because we were in the middle of
wildfires um you know i
uh we spend our summers now we live in
british columbia but we used to spend
our summers here it's where my parents
live
and every summer it goes up in flames
just like california right so how i
would love not to have to explain this
to my kid but he's choking on the smoke
so i all the adults around him are
talking about it so
kids we have not protected our kids this
is the hard truth this is i think
rain why it is so hard to confront this
right is
we have failed in our fundamental duty
as parents which is to protect our kids
and and the we here is not
it's not
we're not all equally responsible and
lots of people have been trying to
change things as as we went but we
collectively as adults have not
protected our kids
if the if we had they wouldn't be
inheriting this world and so
the given that we haven't protected them
given that they are inheriting this um
the least we can do is empower them
right and that's why throughout the book
these stories of incredible young people
like takata like greta
and so many other young people who are
leading climate marches stopping
pipelines suing the u.s government for
failing to protect their future those
are threaded throughout so it isn't just
this the frightening reality of climate
change um that they're reading about
they're also reading about young people
that hopefully they can relate to that
are doing something about it because i
was really impacted by greta tunberg's
personal story
which i'm sure you know you've heard
bits some of i've not you know heard her
speak about it you know and she's given
a wonderful ted talk about it where she
tells this story where when she first
heard about the about climate change
when she was 11
it sent her into such a state of despair
that she couldn't eat or speak right
and so
young people know this is happening and
so if we tell ourselves that we're
protecting them
i think there's a greater risk of losing
them to despair
and i think the best our our best hope
is
encouraging them to join movements so
that they feel that they can do
something about it because
look they're not protected they're not
protected we might i wish we could
protect them so what i hear you saying
is that the way that you can mitigate
some of the
echo
anxiety that you know necessarily comes
with explaining to young people and my
kid my oldest are also nine so
i i i feel you i'm in this place where
you know we we don't talk about climate
change we talk about pollution yes i
feel like those are things you can do
something about
um but what you seem to be saying is
put their energy into action to give
them give them stories of people who
have succeeded in trying to make a
difference and trying to change things
and that's the best way to both inform
them educate them
while at the same time not um
allowing them to kind of
go into kind of a state of nihilism
about the whole thing like why why even
bother yeah and i think i really learned
that from greta and her story where
what pulled her out of that state of
despair was first changing her own
behavior and her own family's behavior
but then starting the the fridays for
future movement and and the climate
strikes and closing that kind of
cognitive dissonance right of
wait a minute if this is all true what
i'm learning at school why is everybody
acting as if everything is normal why
aren't we all treating this like an
emergency
and and so you know when young people go
on climate strike they are declaring a
state of emergency they're saying you
know our job as kids is to go to school
so
by not doing our job there they they are
declaring their own state of emergency
and it's not because they think they're
going to solve the climate crisis by not
going to school they're trying to model
what they want from adults which is wait
a minute this stop acting like
everything is normal
um you know
lay down in front of the train like this
is not working front page headline fox
news naomi klein tells children to lay
down in front of trains
can you believe this liberal activist
telling children to actually lie down in
front of trains hong kong that is the
primary message of the book yes
secondarily i would say the message is
well frankly you know it's a it's an old
one which is that the youth
is our only hope i believe the children
are our future precisely yes that is
exactly the the message one thing they
really do hate the young the youth
if i'm a channel um
is they hate when we tell them that we
are their hope
i was just gonna say that is that number
one yeah because it puts you know puts
this ridiculous amount of responsibility
on those shoulders by the way a
responsibility to fix the things that we
[ __ ] up yeah they're like no you're
not off the hook it also is indicative
of the fact that we've been saying this
for a really long time i feel like like
for every generation
says
the children are our future and the the
youth is the hope and and
and and and even after you know sort of
profound dramatic shifts in our society
you know after 9 11 i remember
i was one of the people saying
9 11 generation is going to change the
way that we think about foreign policy
no uh during the vietnam war vietnam war
is going to change the relationship
between the people and the government
nope nope nope it didn't uh
i just feel like
maybe
maybe we say this so often because
it doesn't seem to
pan out the way that we always hope it
does and i wonder
what you think is particularly unique
about
this generation the generation that
you're writing about
that
makes you hope that maybe this one could
be different they're not going to do it
on their own they don't want to do it on
their own and we do need a
multi-generational movement um
we need to back them up
but what i think is different is
you know when i first started
going to climate marches and listening
to climate scientists
20 years ago
the whole discourse was like we have to
do this for the children we have to do
this for the grandchildren but the
children and the grandchildren were sort
of like
mute um they were not involved in the
discussion um some of them were sort of
notional you know future generations and
so i think that the big shift is that
the children and the grandchildren are
here they're speaking for themselves
they're pissed off
healthy snacks razza oh i've got some
thoughts on healthy snacks do tell i
mean you know look they usually have a
bad reputation sure everybody knows this
let's be honest about it but
this episode
of metaphysical milkshake is sponsored
by monk pacquiao
let me tell you something about monk
packs
addicted to monk pack they make snacks
that taste just like your favorite
sugary treats but with one gram of sugar
or less is there a 12-step program from
monk pack the monk pack keto nut and
seed bars they got this perfect balance
of sweet and salty
that crunch from the whole nuts and
seeds it still manages to be soft and
chewy they come in delicious flavors
like sea salt dark chocolate
caramel sea salt and peanut butter dark
chocolate my favorite one is this like
cocoa and
coconut one i personally love the great
texture of the bars they're not too hard
but they're still crunchy
thanks to all the the nuts and seeds try
it yourself and you'll see you don't
have to take our word for it people and
we have a special deal for our listeners
get 20 off your first purchase of any
monk pack product by visiting monk pack
munk monk pack dot com and entering our
code
milkshake at checkout and monk pack is
so confident in their product it's
backed with 100 satisfaction guaranteed
so if you don't like your monk pack bars
they'll exchange a product no no no send
it to me if you don't like it send it to
me i'll eat it for you or they'll refund
your money whichever you prefer so to
get started go to monkpack.com that's
m-u-n-k-p-a-c-k.com
and select any product enter the code
milkshake at checkout to save 20 off
your purchase monk pack delicious
nutritious food you can count on and
thank you monk pack for sponsoring this
episode of metaphysical milkshake and
send me more bars please
listeners we got sent to manscaped
sample box there are so many so many
ways there's scissors and grooming
clippers and trimmers and tweezers so
our friends at manscaped have a new
fourth generation brand new lawnmower
4.0 kick your pubes to the next planet
with the performance package 4.0 the
orbits in your pants will feel like
you're in zero gravity they're really
going with this metaphor join the two
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped and get your rocket ready for
takeoff hail by going to manscaped.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code
milk shake listen don't mess around here
okay you're talking about your balls all
right yeah you what are you gonna you're
gonna just use anything you don't want
to use little scissors down there no you
poke yourself in the scrotch what if you
sneeze if you're ready for an
out-of-world experience you gotta look
no further than the performance package
4.0 from manscape it's just been taken
off not only in the us by the way but in
canada in uk across europe so inside the
package you're going to find the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed whacker
you're a nose trimmer got that the crop
preserver ball deal i got that and i
used it and my balls are so fresh too
much tmi all right so get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code you know it
milkshake at
manscaped.com so that's 20 off plus free
shipping all you got to do is use the
code milkshake at manscape.com for a
clean
trinity and beyond your spaceballs well
thank you
i think one of the things that has
really
um
you know held us back from acting in the
face of the climate crisis is this idea
that it was this abstract threat that it
was
for some other people to worry about um
and not for the people in the here here
and now to contend with and what when
this generation talks about the climate
crisis crisis they talked about they
talk about
their schools closing because of poor
air quality because of wildfires they
talk about living through hurricane
maria they talk about um having their
lives already disrupted right so i think
that that lends a sense of urgency that
the movement hasn't really had in the
north um in in in richer countries
um
but also i think the biggest shift is
for this generation
it isn't just the climate crisis that
makes them think that they need a
revolution
it's all kinds of things like they see
they they see a system
in overlapping
failure right so for these kids
since they've been paying attention
donald trump was president right that
was a crisis um they have seen
children torn from their parents arms at
the border they
they
um they are they have marched in black
lives matter demonstrations they are
um online and dealing and experience the
failure of tech companies to protect
them right they're dealing with sort of
a predatory information ecology so
i would say that um 10 years ago the
climate movement was like okay we've got
climate change how do we keep things
pretty much exactly how they are but
stop climate change um and that actually
doesn't work
um well for those listening who may not
know why doesn't that work because i
talk about this a lot like you know the
the the impulse uh 10 years ago was like
we've got to stop co2 and methane and
and we do and we certainly need to stop
co2 and methane and that's got to be a
top priority but it goes way deeper than
that but for those listening that may
not quite get that what's your nutshell
version okay well even just talking
about co2 and methane right um
the these
there there are
some of the richest companies on the
planet
that
are valued based on
their reserves of carbon
and methane and their entire evaluation
in the market has to do with not just
what they are producing right now but
the fact that they've laid claim to
huge amounts of fossil fuels that they
have not yet that they have not yet even
started to dig up but those are their
fossil fuel reserves um
and so that is worth trillions of
dollars um
and so
it is actually a really big challenge to
capitalism to say um you know
that 20 trillion dollars worth of carbon
um you need to leave it in the ground
we're going to wipe that off the books
that is exactly what the international
energy agency just said in a report that
came out on may 18th that we cannot
build new fossil fuel infrastructure we
can't have new fossil fuel projects we
actually need to start winding down
existing fossil fuel infrastructure so
the problem isn't that we can't do wind
and solar it's that we've got
these um
we've got these kind of carbon bombs
right that are bombs for the planet but
they're also bombs for the market right
so
it isn't just like a little technical
problem to say we can't burn that it
actually is a huge problem for
capitalism to contend with that reality
um
but then i think underneath it and
deeper than that and that's i think what
you're getting at is that it's it's not
just a technical sort of co2 problem
it's a consumption problem it is
what we think we need in order to lead
good lives 70
of the fossil fuel of
emissions of greenhouse gas emissions
come from 20 of the wealthiest people on
the planet so it isn't everybody on the
planet who's over consuming it's 20
of people on the planet who are over
consuming and we have a definition of a
good life that that is every generation
has more than the generation before more
and more and more it doesn't contend
with limits
and so
the deeper crisis is we have to live
within the earth's limits we can't just
treat the planet as it as if it is our
limitless
superstore
right uh to deplete
you said that the the deeper problem
really is a consumption problem i would
go even further and say that the problem
is a relationship problem and it's a
relationship problem of ourselves to the
planet
uh
and ourselves to each other and you
write in your book the earth is not our
prisoner our patient our machine or
indeed our monster it is our entire
world and the solution to global warming
is not to fix the world it is to fix
ourselves easy yeah super easy the
problem is human nature that should just
like take care of not human nature it's
a certain worldview it's a certain
worldview of certain humans let's just
go back to the very beginning because
where and when do you think humanity
went wrong because one issue that i have
with like let's call it the political
left but or the academic left is me you
mean me well it is you it's become very
easy to kind of blame all of this
on
capitalism and imperialism of the last
400 years like as if this all started
with columbus and it all started with
like the
the east india tea company or something
like that and then has gotten us to the
modern day but
i want to get to the roots of this like
this is an ancient human problem this
relationship problem that we're talking
about humans to the earth and humans to
each other so but how would you put your
finger on when and where we went wrong
so i do believe colonialism has a hell
of a lot to answer for colonialism like
in like the mongolian invasion that
colonialism or
so i think that this this idea that it
is human nature
i'm not saying that
humans have not waged war depleted
resources since before european
colonialism they have
but it's also true
that many
many people
managed to live in
a relationship to nature
that
was regenerative that was relational
and
that when we tell this certain kind of
story that says it is
just something inherent in all humans
that they just want to destroy where
they live and deplete where they live
i don't know where that leaves
indigenous communities
that had relationships to the land that
were
so spiritual and
um
and and
and
were
you know beyond relationships of
stewardship but actually relationships
based on the idea that all of life is
literal relatives
um now i'm speaking to you from british
columbia okay i'm just gonna get real
like like this will get a bit heavy
let's get real a few days ago in not far
from where i am in british columbia
an indigenous community um uh
issued a press release um in it the
first nation is called the sequential
um in the interior of bc
and
they said that they had this news that
was absolutely devastating to have to
share
which is that they had
done
a radar surveys of the land of where a
former
residential school a boarding school
where they took um indigenous children
for many decades
had found that there was a mass grave
site and you probably heard about this a
mass grave site where they found uh the
bodies of 215 uh children including
children as young as as three
now this is something that we knew
happened in canada that we knew that
people disappeared in the residential
schools and there was a there was a
truth and reconciliation
um
uh report that came out a few years ago
after interviewing hundreds of survivors
and doing deep deep research
and they found in the the in the report
they didn't just
lay out what happened they talked about
why it happened why were indigenous
people
banned from
practicing their ceremonies speaking
their language why was their hair cut
why were the children taken from their
parents
and it and they concluded that it was in
order to sever their relationship with
the land so that they could have these
extractive policies that people were
were standing in the way of so
um you know i think
i i don't think we should just dismiss
the idea that colonialism um was one
group of people
violently wrenchingly brutally imposing
a world view that saw
relationships a worldview where you
would see all of life as your relative
as such a threat
that children were killed
for practicing what they were told was a
satanic religion
because believing in animism believing
you know
having a spirituality that represented
animals you know in carvings was seen as
satan worship right that has a ton to
answer for in why
we find ourselves um treating the world
as a machine
and
i know that people like jared diamond
have written these books that tell
people oh humans have always done this
i've always depleted the earth and i
just don't accept from what i've seen in
indigenous communities and you know you
should interview
an indigenous person and it will answer
this for you to you better than me
that this is just human nature and i
think when we say it's human nature
um
that feeds us that a sense of
helplessness like if it is just
this is just something inherent in us
all humans just destroy their habitat
then there is no hope we should
absolutely throw in the towel but if
this is actually a system that we can
make visible and a world view that said
actually there's a hierarchy of humanity
there's god on top there's angels
underneath then there's white men then
there's white women and just go on down
until there's like rocks and trees which
are
less worthless
that world view is what allows you to
treat the earth as if you know anything
that stands in the way of the oil or the
gold or whatever it is is just you know
the mining industry calls it overburden
that's the way
that's the way they view the natural
world not everybody on this planet sees
the natural world that way sees trees
and soil as overburdened that is a
particular way of seeing the world and
it is a way that has gotten us into the
mess we're in
folks if you know anything about us you
know that we can't get enough of one
dream one dream one dream
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m-wandrium it's a
streaming service
that brings you mind-blowing moments
into your everyday lives if you're
familiar with the great courses plus oh
yeah yeah then you already know one
dream it's the same great service but
now there's even more to learn and to
love with onedrive you can explore
thousands of hours of fascinating video
and audio content documentaries
tutorials
travel logs
find answers to questions we've always
wondered about and uh even questions
that we've never even thought to ask
yeah so
we recommend checking out hey hey author
of zealot best-selling new york times
author of zealot it's no joke this is
the kind of stuff that i'm totally into
so right now i'm so into the history and
archaeology of the bible like it's just
such a great refresher for me it it
views the stories of the bible from a
historical and archaeological lens it's
my jam
so
we know you're going to love one dream
listeners as much as we do please use
our special url so they know that we
sent you rain and reza go to
onedrive.com just do this go to
onedream.com
milkshake and for a limited time sign up
and you'll get a free month trial of
unlimited access that's one dram
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash milkshake again one dream
dot com slash milkshake sign up today
it'll make you smarter so i got my
second shipment of magic spoon
okay so four new boxes all four flavors
i keep them at my desk i didn't even put
them in the kitchen magic spoon this
magic cereal that i'm talking about has
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein only four net grams of carbs in
each serving i don't know how they do
this it has only 140 calories a serving
keto friendly
gluten-free grain free soy free low carb
gmo free this no this can't be true have
you tried mixing the peanut butter and
the chocolate together like you put it
together that sounds grab one fistful of
each shove it in your giant mouth it's
like eating a peanut i do have a big
mouth yeah it's like regular cereal from
your childhood remember that but it's
super nutritious it's a delicious but
super healthy cereal it really brings
joy to your mornings or afternoons or
dinners or snacks or late night snacks
so this is what you do go to
magicspoon.com milkshake and grab a
variety pack and try it today and be
sure to use our promo code milkshake at
checkout to save five dollars off of
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's back
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com milkshake and use the
code milkshake to save five dollars off
you know
magic spoon with a milkshake poured on
top of it
oh with an actual milk i'm gonna go do
that right now go to in-n-out burger get
a milkshake pour it on the magic spoon
i'm done i'm doing that right now thank
you magic spoon for sponsoring this
episode
you know rayne and i we we as you can uh
already tell we we have a lot of
different disagreements about you know
we we we share the same values we share
the same world with you frankly but i
think we we have different ideas about
how to achieve
um you know the goals that we have in
common
and
fundamental to that debate is a debate
that's actually raging right now you
know with the biden administration and
with progressives on one side and you
know whatever center democrats on the
other whatever but this idea that
there are
unquestionable undeniable
uh foundational problems with our
society with our government with our
world
but is the proper way to fix those
problems the proper way to address them
is it to work within the system
to turn screws make incremental changes
fix this and that in hopes that the
results will will be better
or
is the answer
to kind of start from the beginning and
and
uh you know burn the whole system down
start with the foundation
i mean the one the one thing i would
just clarify is
it's capitalists who are unbelievably
radical like it's it it's it's
capitalism that is burning it down okay
that's a good point yeah it's actually a
sort of a strange reversal what climate
change does to this conversation because
if you look at what those young people
are doing who sort of inform you know
they're they they look scruffy and
they're occupying nancy pelosi's office
and things like that
their message is actually pretty
conservative they're like we want a
future um
and it's like joe manchin who's like
let's let the whole thing burn let's let
the whole thing burn yeah exactly what i
believe is that the future is radical
one way or another and we are having a
conversation about what kind of radical
we want because if we stay on the road
we are on and do those sort of like
little incremental changes it takes us
to an incredibly radical place
both physically in terms of what will
happen to the natural world but also
politically and socially in terms of
what it looks like
when that pyramid society when a society
that is intensely hierarchical that has
not challenged its inherent white
supremacy um
confronts
that that scarcity in crisis it looks
like hoarding it looks like fortress
borders it looks like a resurgence of
just unmasked kind of eco-fascism of
like well maybe climate change is a
culling maybe this is god's will um
that's not my problem i mean it's it's
not hard to imagine
what the people who already
subscribe to that intensely hierarchical
world view
how they will start to rationalize
the reality of climate disruption once
they get past the denial and they are
starting to get past it um it's like
well maybe it's good that there'll be
fewer people on the planet right and as
long as me and mine are fine um
so
that is one form of radicalism i think
it's a really bad form of radicalism and
we should do everything else to with
everything in our power to avoid it but
in order to avoid it that's going to
take some really radical
pull economic and political change so
the idea that one of our choices is
things staying kind of as they are and
us sort of tinkering
that's not one of the options on the
table like there isn't a scenario where
where where the future is just like the
present uh only with a few tweaks the
radicalism
we're in like we just come through covid
barely you know like we are in an era of
big shocks and big changes
and the question is do we just let them
happen because we're too afraid of
political and economic change or do we
try to shape this somehow i'm in a 100
percent agreement um
and i think the system the systemic
change needs to be uh tremendous and
earth shattering earth shaking
um because it's the future of our earth
and i love the word
radical but let me just pose this i'm
going off script a little bit part of
the radical systemic change we're
talking about is not just politics right
i mean it's a radical systemic change on
our relationship to stuff and how we
consume and how we relate one to another
i agree and that i think brings us back
to this question of
what is the crisis and is it a you know
i i think it is a crisis of world view
um
and it is a crisis of consumption of
over consumption which is intimately
connected to that because i think we are
more and more forming our identities
through what we consume
and a lot of the ways that we you know
as humans have traditionally formed
group identities and had a sense of
belonging
are
in decline you know one of the reasons
why i've been such a strong proponent of
the green new deal
as a response to the climate crisis is
that
it's a framework that is
that draws on american history and at a
time in american history
when there was a sense of collective
mission and purpose
and you know when you see that kind of
frantic frenetic over consumption right
that you're referring to
i always ask okay what are people really
shopping for like is it is it actually
the thing they're buying or is it
or is it fitting in
self-esteem connection community
i mean you you probably remember this
from
becoming you know parents for the first
time but some some of the biggest over
consumers are new parents right oh
totally and it's not just we are suckers
we're suckers because we're scared
you're in a state of extreme insecurity
when you're about to become a parent for
the first time right that is so true and
it's like i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
doing i need that bouncy chair like i
need three of them like i you know and
it's like i i remember that when i first
first became a mom like i've never
shopped like that before i'm really
embarrassed because when i was pregnant
i was like i'm not going to buy anything
i'm just going to like it's all going to
be hand-me-down
bespoke warmers for the for the you know
like the wipes now you don't just have
audio monitors you've got to have the
video monitor yeah
as well as changes ours like changes
colors and sounds i had like a swing for
my son that was just like a light show
and diaper genie
i mean it just uh whatever like
first-time parents we will buy anything
and it comes from a place of raw terror
yep here and a lot of consumption does
right so yeah coming back to the green
new deal
the the stuff that i love most about the
original new deal are like the civilian
conservation corps where
two million young people you know 18 to
21 went out and planted trees two
billion trees um learned about forest
ecology
or
the huge programs that funded murals and
theater and and this is this was group
activity that filled the need for
belonging and identity and mission
and i just think that you don't get at
over consumption by wagging your finger
and telling people that they're idiots
and bad because they want that thing you
try to fill the thing that people are
shopping for
um that isn't the thing that they're
buying um in some other way
um and and so
yeah i think we need to think about how
do how do we
how do we give people that sense of
belonging and identity and mission and
purpose
and you know
stopping climate change is a pretty good
mission
um
and we need we need young people need
stuff to do right now there's a huge
youth unemployment crisis
and mental health crisis at the core of
this argument about
incremental versus systemic change and
the new deal is the the model of what
i'm talking about here and so is the
green new deal
is
this kind of
willingness
to simply say we are in a state of
emergency
joe manchin you can go [ __ ] yourself
okay uh that we're just gonna plow
through you instead of trying to find
you know common cause with people
who are destroying our future
joe manchin can go [ __ ] himself but the
people who joe manchin represents should
get jobs and
amazing green infrastructure
and the constituency for the green new
deal should be built around joe manchin
um so i think that we we've equated this
idea of of bipartisanship and and
reaching across difference to this
really really narrow
group of people in washington dc um who
are doing actually a pretty poor job of
representing the people who put them
there um and that was i think one of the
really great things and i
you know fdr did a lot of terrible
things let's you know he interned
japanese americans the the original new
deal
um you know was during the jim crow era
and there was um rampant discrimination
and who received relief women were
excluded
from many of the key programs
he did get some things really right and
he got a lot of things wrong um one of
the things he got right i think was his
attitude of just taking it to the people
right so if you i mentioned this the the
the civilian conservation corps this
amazing program that planted more than
two billion trees that's more than half
the trees ever planted in the history of
the us
um
800 state parks were built by the
civilian
conservation corps
we still benefit from so much of that
infrastructure
so if you look at where he cited the ccc
camps
he cited them
it must have been deliberately in many
of the communities that voted against
him the first time he ran for president
um and he flipped them so if you go then
and look at the at the voting map in in
1936 many of those red districts flipped
blue and they had new deal programs
right so that's bipartisan it's just go
moving around a sort of the the
obstructionist and it is in
local communities where i think you you
have the best opportunities to
reach across
the real aisle you know for people to
come into conversation with their
neighbors find common ground and the
idea that we just
allow the senate to represent you know
what that conversation should look like
i think is really flawed one of the
things that um i
love about your work and one of the most
inspiring cool things i've ever heard in
my life i heard you talk about uh this
leap yeah we wrote a document called the
leap manifesto you you brought together
a coalition of disparate groups seeking
change in all different respects some
were union groups some are education
groups environmental groups uh native
indigenous groups and you and you
decided to come up with a manifest
manifesto of what does the future look
like what do we want the future to look
like what are we striving for and this
is such a brilliant concept because all
of these little disparate organizations
working in their you know in their
little beehives and and i think
culturally we're in this kind of point
where um a lot of the mistake that we're
making currently is kind of like
pointing out and protesting injustice
but but but that's all we do it's like
hey there's an injustice that's terrible
oh look there's another injustice that's
bad oh my god there's another injustice
oh that's terrible but this idea of like
coming together and and saying
what do we ultimately striving for
um
so that we have something to shoot for
it gives all of us
in the struggle no matter what our path
may be a path forward can you tell us
more about this uh
idea and organization the core
principles of the leap are the core
principles of environmental justice of
climate justice which are the first one
is
front lines first so the idea that the
people who got the shittiest deal in our
current economy of extraction who have
the fossil fuel projects in their
backyards whose lands have been polluted
need to be first in line to own and
control their own green infrastructure
their own renewable energy so it's a
process of really making reparation uh
for the for harm done
another core principle
is that no workers should be left behind
so workers who lose their jobs in high
carbon sectors
need to be guaranteed jobs at the same
salary level at the same benefit level
um in the in the low-carbon economy uh
another core principle is that care work
is climate work and we need to invest in
the in the parts of our economy that
actually um
increase well-being much much more than
consumption uh increased consumption um
and the other one is and sorry if this
is mean to joe manchin it's polluters
should pay
because i actually believe that justice
isn't just
that the people who
have been hurt by this system benefit
it's also that the people who cause the
harm actually have to be accountable for
that we have to just get on the right
track and give people a taste of what
that change could look like because i
think that once we start having that
lived experience then we just want more
of it and your view what does this leap
forward
better
future world actually look like yeah i
think
at the heart of it is decolonization um
and
in the people whose land was stolen are
still around it didn't work we didn't
wipe out indigenous cultures um
and
[Music]
one of the things i would love to see is
a return of
that civilian conservation corps where
we repair some of the damage we've done
to the earth where we plant huge numbers
of trees but it's indigenous people who
get their land back and are in charge of
that
and lead us in a spiritual revolution
rain because i think it is can be pretty
spiritual to get a lot of people out on
the land planting trees if we do it
right if they're not tree farms um you
know but it's actually about
being back in relationship with the land
and each other um and i've you know
been in some spaces like that and it
really can change the way you see the
world naomi klein thank you so much for
uh this incredible conversation but hold
on you thought it was over what we do
with every guest is a
what reza i believe it's called a
lightning round i have test phobia by
the way well you are being graded no big
deal but malcolm gladwell got an a he
did so well on this
all right we'll ask you a question and
then you just answer with kind of the
first thing that comes to your mind are
you ready what skill do you wish you had
i wish i could sing
like rain what is something you would
change about yourself if you could oh i
wish i was more patient
um with my adorable son
what's one habit that you're most proud
of
i can't not write
i guess i cannot write
that's fine
for me it's like an itch like i'm like
why am i so uncomfortable oh it's
because i didn't write
yeah and then it's like i i i act like
somebody's making me and then it's like
no it's just you yeah when do you feel
most connected with the universe i feel
most connected to the universe um
like i said i'm in british columbia
we've still got some beautiful big giant
cedars here
um probably probably the forest if you
could have coffee with a 15 year old
naomi klein what would you tell her
oh dear 15 was a rough rough rough age
[Music]
you are never ever going to have to see
those girls again oh that's a good one
what is one book that has changed your
life
it's a little bit cliche for for for a
climate writer but um rachel carson's
silent spring unsurpassed for me what
three items would you take with you on a
deserted island i definitely bring like
a guide to the stars so that i could um
because i wouldn't have much to do um
i bring like a mask so that i could go
snorkeling and look at the fishies
because i think i'd need like a friend's
company with the fishes and
um
notebook
oh geez three so now i don't have a pen
uh describe your soul in 10 words or
less
reaching
um
awestruck
loving
i love that
three good ones that's great and then
finally what is your life's big question
are we gonna get our [ __ ] together
in time
yeah
well you're doing something about that
so you're doing your utmost to try and
make sure that we are and that we do
and i seriously applaud you for that
because that is it is hard work what you
do and
bless you this book is fantastic i'm
gonna buy a bushel of them and give them
to uh
a bunch of like 11 to 14 year olds yeah
makes a great christmas present it's
pretty radical i will warn you parents
it is radical and it is worth it they're
ready for it
wow so naomi's uh life's big question
was
hey humanity are we gonna get our [ __ ]
together in time reza any thoughts on
that and maybe piece that together with
this systemic change you're blathering
on and on about i mean look you know i
want to say yes i really want to say yes
but i look at
not just you know our politics and i i
hear you like we we sometimes focus too
much on politics maybe it's because we
feel like it's something we can [ __ ]
about
but even about our world views the fact
that the human condition
in my view is entropy
and it it really makes me nervous
whether we can get our [ __ ] together in
time so if i
had to say
if the only answers were yes and no
i'm gonna say no well i don't think the
only answers are yes or no i mean i view
it as listen i have a bunch of relatives
that um i had to put into rehab okay
like serious like heroin
rehab
and for me it's kind of like humanity is
a junkie where
we're jumped out on oil
and stuff
and distraction
um and it's non-stop and we're we're
going to hit bottom
it's just how bad are we going to hit
bottom that's it you know it's good
things are going to get really bad
there's going to be you know the whole
syria war by the way which caused this
huge migration and this this giant you
know
crisis of immigrants in europe and
greece and blah blah blah that we've
been hearing about started from climate
change you know it started from uh the
worst drought in the middle eastern
history that's right so we're going to
get a lot more of that kind of stuff
going on and you know millions will
suffer there's going to be a tremendous
amount of suffering it's just how bad
and and that's always up to the addict
how how bad how low do they need to go
before they clean up their act and drag
their ass to rehab and throw up their
hands and say i'm powerless i have an
addiction
i'm i'm over this i throw in the white
nothing else is working nothing is just
working i whatever you tell me to do i'm
gonna do
and you drag to rehab and then you know
you you sip orange juice and sit in a
circle and
um talk about your feelings
[Music]
what do you think dear listener uh are
we gonna get our [ __ ] together uh
how can we change everything are the
children
our future i believe the children are
our future i've heard you i've heard you
believe that
all right metaphysical fans we
are about to record our favorite segment
our newly favorite segment where we
respond to listener voicemails
some of our listeners who have pondered
some of our life's biggest questions to
potentially have you on the show to chat
with you to visit with you to hear about
your life's biggest questions to hear
your thoughts on the episodes please
leave a rating and a review on apple
podcasts telling us what your life's
biggest question is screenshot it then
tag us on instagram at metaphysical
milkshake and we'll be selecting a few
people to chat with we would love to
have you so for this episode we've got a
few interesting voicemails some good
comments let's run the first one this is
from akash
how do we change everything to save the
climate i think saving is a cover-up our
humans we humans want to feed our ego
and we want to create destructive things
in order to have positive things in
contrast so that we can get a lot of
stories out of it
people have been doing so much work
since forever but we're still not able
to save the climate because i think
everything boils down to our ego and not
really saving it so if we stop creating
destructive things there is no need to
actually save or
do in contrast
and in summary but if you really want to
do it i think we should stop eating
non-veg we should stop killing animals
because the amount of pain that gets
released in the environment and we know
everything is energy right everything
every atom solid say liquids it doesn't
matter everything is energy and energy
is in momentum always it's moving so the
amount of pain that is released the
amount of carbon dioxide the water the
wastage that is released into the
environment it affects us nobody knows
us but if we are conscious of it right
and i feel yeah if we do stop
eating consuming non-veg humans will
still live it's not like we're all going
to die because there is no meat on the
planet earth in day one so i think uh
yeah we should stop eating that
okay he's got a point yeah what do you
think like if there's one act let's just
say like of all the different things
that you could do
to save this planet
if there's one
thing
that rises above the rest it would be
yeah stop eating meat now i'm this is
coming from a meat eater by the way um
but
i agree and uh well you're persian you
eat kebab yeah i have a choice it's it's
culture for me so i don't really have
but you know like i i i'm eating less
and less meat you're eating less and
less meat and we're getting the
technologies now i mean have you had an
impossible burger [ __ ] is good fantastic
it is i mean it's 40 but whatever but
it's really
really good and i think that you know
talking about what can we do to maybe
save the environment in the future
i think eventually replacing real meat
with fake meat might not be such a bad
idea thanks akash i always tell young
people the number one way if you want to
do something about climate change is to
stop eating
beef
now you can stop eating red meat you can
stop eating all meat none of it's good
but beef is and i loved how he conflated
um pain
and carbon dioxide it's like stop eating
meat
and stop causing pain and stop releasing
so much carbon dioxide and what a
perfect integration of the spiritual and
the scientific uh at the same time i
let's just skip the pain part for the
time being which may or may not be true
because animals die and you can kill
them ethically i suppose um
but
uh it is absolutely true the amount of
waste that uh goes hand in hand with
meat eating is
astronomical i don't need to say it here
everyone knows about control the amount
of water and soybean feed for the cows
deforestation which adds to climate
change on its own cow methane farts and
burps um it is um it is no bueno so good
okay so how do we change everything
start with your own diet folks there you
have it i think we got somebody else
here uh andrew
yeah so i want to talk about
the climate change question
um and unfortunately
i actually think that we unless we
drastically change everything including
how we operate
our day-to-day lives and
the economic system we are in
we're
doomed we we desperately need to get
away from
oil consumption
and along and all this long distance
travel that relies on it the plastics
all of this
is is building up and building up
and
in order to save the climate we need to
trash
capitalism and
and less into a lesser extent
trash
globalism
we need to focus on
doing everything that we can
to make and create locally
while
holding other people accountable as well
and i just don't think we have the
ability to do that with how reliable we
are on
the technologies we have
created that are based on this
endless extraction and exploitation of
the environment that's a great idea what
i'd like to do is stop using oil to heat
my house and instead use andrew's
sonorous voice
yeah i mean this is listen anytime you
have a discussion about changing the
world and especially around climate
you start to unpack it and more and more
you realize that our whole system
the foundationally needs to change the
the kind of consumerist culture that we
live in
um
that is uh capitalist and product uh
profit seeking rather
um is
it's not sustainable so i'm sorry all
you capitalists out there
you know
we don't really have a better system
than capitalism as far as i'm concerned
but something has got to change because
this um i was just reading this article
today on uh the environmental impact of
these giant cargo ships that go back and
forth between china and the us and china
and europe just chalk a block filled
with stuff from you know ping-pong balls
to flip-flops to baseball caps to you
know butterscotch and
anything else you can think of
toothbrushes and
we can't
it can't sustain it just can't sustain i
don't know what what new can we say
about this idea reza i mean look if
you're gonna have a conversation about
how to change everything and you're not
putting fossil fuels on the table then
what the [ __ ] are you doing like i'm not
interested in this conversation then uh
you know this was great i mean look
people are constantly like you know
the problems of the world are so big you
know how can we tackle them and i
totally feel you i i'm i'm in the same
boat
but what i love about these two callers
akash and uh andrew is that each of them
basically said the one thing that you
could do that would literally change
everything sure stop eating at least you
know beef
and
get rid of fossil fuels done do you do
those two things
and you have changed everything and then
throw in kind of buy and support locally
support buying locally as opposed to the
one click of the amazon button which i
am a little bit addicted to
you know i hear you um
so
there you have it well that was great uh
thank you callers we'd love to hear from
you please uh write us at metaphysical
milkshake on instagram please again over
and over again we're gonna say it like
follow subscribe rate review on apple
podcasts we'd love to hear from you and
we love
folding our listeners and viewers into
the discussion
you can find us on socials at reza aslan
and rayne wilson we are also on twitter
at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram
at metaphysical milkshake let us know
let us know your life's big questions on
said socials
and we might just explore them on a
future episode and please remember to
follow rate like review metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcasts and wherever
else you listen to your gt podcasts and
of course you can also subscribe
to the metaphysical milkshake youtube
channel watch our full episodes every
week assuming there is a future
if there is we will see you in it if we
don't see you in the future well then
you know what happened well that's it
the writing was on the wall thank you
naomi klein for doing the deep dive with
us and the whole milkshake team thank
you so much everybody we'll see you very
soon
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle original music is
composed by jeff tang
he has a msnbc logo tattooed on his back
naomi
it's a [ __ ] stamp right right at the
lower back